hi this is pressure Locker in this video
we're going to discuss the 15 puzzle you
may have played sliding puzzles there
were certainly a part of my childhood
you had to slide around the blocks until
you bring them into a solved
configuration which would be some sort
of picture while this may not seem that
interesting to you now in the 1880s
there was a sliding block puzzle called
the 15 puzzle which took over all of
America and drove the world crazy you
can read about it in the book the 15
puzzle I've left two linked in the
description it's really well researched
and it tells you things like Sam Lloyd
was not the inventor of the puzzle in
this video we're going to create our own
15 puzzle I've provided a template for
you to print out there's a link in the
description and there are two images one
is a 4x4 grid and the other are 15
blocks numbered 1 through 15 so print
those out and carefully cut out the
discs with the numbers 1 through 15 you
can cut them out one by one or if you're
more daring you can stack them up once
you have them all printed out we're
going to put them in the order 1 through
15 and then flip the numbers 14 and 15
so here's what they look like on the
board we have 1 through 15
we then flip 14 and 15 the puzzle is
only moving disks inside the grid you
need to return the pieces back into
numerical order 1 through 15
to preempt people who say the puzzle
cannot be solved here's a picture of the
puzzle solve as stated in the video if
you watch this video closely there are
at least three different clues there
subtle clues you can think about it like
an episode of Sherlock so give the
puzzle a try I'm going to present the
solution next week I hope you liked this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can get my books listed on my website
catch me on my blog line your decisions
on Twitter at pressure Locker and you
can support me at patreon to get
exclusive rewards